[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans cette
édition du jeudi 6 juin sur tv 78 voici
les titres de ce journal l'est
républicain qui s'effrite un peu plus
après la démission de laurent wauquiez
valérie pécresse qui clôt partie la
président de la région ile-de-france
l'annoncé hier et dans le sillage de
l'hybride noise d'autres départs d'élus
du département est les réactions à
suivre il a été présenté officiellement
aujourd'hui laurent fournier le nouvel
entraîneur de l'as poissy football
l'ancien joueur du paris saint germain
s'est engagé pour une année de contrat
le coach aura la tâche de faire remonter
le club
et puis le début du bac 2010 9 c dans
onze jours première épreuve le 17 juin
avec la philosophie à la proche de
l'examen la médiathèque du canal à
montigny le bretonneux propose des
coachings on en parle avec emmanuel
guillery coordinatrice des actions
culturelles pour les adolescents mais
j'accueille tout de suite dans ce
journal mans première invitée c'est
martorell bonsoir bonsoir
alors vous êtes le maire de noisy le roi
et vous assurer l'intérim à la tête de
la fédération eu des idées yvelines
puisque son président paul martinez a
démissionné la semaine dernière
on en parle avec vous dans un instant et
aussi de la suite des événements pour
votre fédération mais d'abord forcément
cette crise qui se confirme au sein du
parti à l'est républicain avec le
mauvais score historique aux européennes
et le départ de laurent wauquiez c'est
valérie pécresse qui claquent la porte
l'ancien député des yvelines qui avait
lancé son un mouvement libre en 2017
souhaite l'émergence d'une troisième
voie entre la république en marche et le
rassemblement national est la présidente
de la région ile de france estime que la
reconstruction de la droite ne peut se
faire au sein du parti les républicains
elle a annoncé son départ dont le 20
heures de france 2 hier soir écouter
je crois que nous devons refonder la
droite elle est menacée d'extinction et
il faut se remettre au travail
mais en femme libre j'ai décidé de
quitter l'est républicain j'ai décidé de
quitter les républicains parce que j'ai
acquis la conviction que la refondation
la droite ne pourra pas se faire à
l'intérieur et qu'elle doit se faire à
l'extérieur du parti
sollicité par notre rédaction plusieurs
élus les républicains d yves lennon pas
souhaité commenter
ce départ tout de même une réaction à
vous proposer celle de pierre bédier qui
s'est exprimé dans les colonnes de nos
confrères du parisien le président l ère
du conseil départemental des yvelines ne
comprend pas le choix de valérie
pécresse selon ses mots créé plusieurs
courants au sein de la droite va
renforcer le capharnaüm actuel pierre
bédier la fiente si valérie pécresse
avait souhaité prendre la tête du parti
il était prêt à la soutenir et dans le
sillage de valérie pécresse les
défections également de plusieurs élus
franciliens à commencer par alexandra
dublanche vice-présidente et de la
région ile de france et maire adjointe
de sartrouville quitté l'est républicain
est un déchirement est minime et lille
il en va de la survie de la droite selon
elle avec sandra du blanche qui était
jusqu'à présent vice présidente de la
fédération les républicains dit yvelines
lui aussi est très très proche de
valérie pécresse c'est othman nana
through qui soutient la démarche de
l'illinois zh mais le président du
groupe l air au conseil régional
d'ile-de-france ne quitte pas le parti
pour le moment écoutez ses explications
au micro de patrick jacques de dixmude
ça fait deux ans que comme d'autres je
dis qu'il ya des choses qui ne vont pas
au sein de la gestion des républicains
la réalité c'est qu'aujourd'hui
mon sujet est avant tout le sujet de la
ville qui m'a élu en 2014 savard trappe
à laquelle je me consacre pleinement et
donc en l'occurrence les questions
d'appareil ne sont pas mon sujet mais en
l'occurrence je dirige un groupe à la
région que je vais réunir pour en
discuter entre nous je vais leur dire
mon sentiment et je reviendrai ensuite
vers vous pour vous dire quelle est ma
décision mais encore une fois le temps
des étiquettes des appareils
il n'est pas devant nous il plutôt
derrière long par contre aujourd'hui
c'est le temps du local et celui qui est
co qui est également conseiller
municipal d'opposition à trappes a réuni
la presse cet après midi pour la
deuxième fois othman nasri sera candidat
aux élections municipales dans la ville
scrutin au programme l'an prochain face
à lui le maire sortant divers gauche guy
malandain elle la candidature sans
étiquette de mustapha larbaoui même s'il
n'a pas indiqué encore s'il était la
tête de liste ou simple colistiers
othman natrue qui sera l'invité du 7-8
journal mardi prochain marc bourrel avec
moi sur ce plateau
vous êtes le délégué départemental par
intérim de l'ue 10,78 de suite au départ
de paul martinez quel regard vous portez
sur la crise actuelle que traverse le
parti les républicains mais écoutez ça
c'est le départ de valérie pécresse
montre s'il était besoin encore de le
prouver qu'il ya un malaise au sein des
républicains à la fois sur le choix de
la tête de liste aux dernières élections
européennes sur les questions sociétales
mais également sur le projet européen
valérie pécresse c'est avait déjà
s'était déjà exprimé là dessus
et puis ça montre que la recomposition
politique qui a démarré avec l'élection
des manuels macro il y a deux ans est
toujours en oeuvre et qu'elle n'est pas
encore achevée alors une situation qui
est également compliquée au sein de
votre formation l'union des démocrates
et indépendants qui a totalisé un score
de 2 49% aux élections européennes ça
c'est au niveau national au niveau des
yvelines s'est un peu plus de 3,1 à 15%
récoltés on rappelle qu'en 2014 vous
étiez allié avec le modem et vous aviez
récoltés pour ce scrutin 13 58 % au
niveau national
alors le président de la fédération de
lui des idées yvelines a démissionné la
semaine dernière paul martinez démission
également de l'un de vos vice-président
de nif est votre avis sur ces
défection est ce que vous les regrettés
vous les comprenez peut-être bien
évidemment que je les regrette nous
avions une excellente collaboration avec
avec paul martinez qui depuis quatre ans
avait réussi à faire une unité autour
autour de lui sur cette fédération des
yvelines et voilà je n'avais imav et on
avait partagé à un certain nombre de
choses notamment sur la stratégie de
l'ue des ouïghours les européennes
je savais qu'il avait des doutes à ce
sujet là il avait pris le temps de me
prévenir de son départ quelques jours
avant oui ça tombe ça tombe mal après la
déception des européennes le départ de
paul ney n'est pas une bonne nouvelle
il nous faut donc maintenant reprendre
le flambeau et voilà la première chose
que l'on va faire j'ai pris le temps de
deux consulte et claire chaillou forains
et bertrand coq harkis sont les les deux
autres vice-présidents et nous sommes
tombés d'accord pour réunir les
militants nous le ferons le 2 juillet
avec cet objectif déjà qui est de de
leur laisser la parole pour avoir un
temps d'échangé d'expression et puis
pour voir plus loin
on a parlé tout à l'heure dans vos dans
vos reportages d'échéance nous pour nous
c'est les municipales et notre boulot en
tant que responsable politique au sein
du diy ben ça va être de permettre à nos
militants à nos élus et bien de prendre
toute leur place dans leurs villes dans
les bonnes équipes pour qu' il puisse
faire ce travail formidable d'élu de
terrain mieux nous préparer à ces
élections ici alors paul martin vous
l'avez évoqué regrette le le choix de
l'indépendance en décider par votre
parti au niveau national le fait de
partir seul pour ces élections
européennes sans alliance avec d'autres
listes ça a été une erreur selon vous
deux
de le faire voilà en indépendant alors
je pense qu'il est encore trop tôt pour
le dire c'est une stratégie on a pris le
temps d'en discuter de façon de façon
très libre
c'est une stratégie que moi même j'avais
j'avais partagé j'avais soutenu parce
que c'est vrai que l'élection est
heureux européenne est typiquement
l'élection qui nous convient c'est notre
adn europe
il y avait un beau projet que
malheureusement jean christophe lagarde
n'a pas pu défendre jusqu'au bout parce
que on l'a vu cette bipolarisation de la
vie politique est bien un petit peu
effacé tout avec ce match macron macron
le pen qui n'a pas permis véritablement
l'émergence de débats bon il faudra que
les conclusions se tirer en tout cas que
l'euro ont rebondi ce maintenant sur sur
notre façon de d'adapter une stratégie
en vue des prochaines échéances qui
arrivent rapidement
jean christophe lagarde qui est le
président lui dit au niveau national
justement quel avenir pour le centre
désormais alors pour la droite valérie
pécresse espère l'émergence d'une
troisième voie entre la république en
marche et le rassemblement national ce
qui à lui des on est dans le même état
d'esprit on pourrait peut-être
s'associer à une démarche de valérie
pécresse jean christophe lagarde l'a
déjà exprimé enfin c'est notre espace à
nous l'espace entre les républicains et
et la république en marche
bon voilà je pense que à chaque jour
suffit sa peine
l'annoncé est toute fraîche nous nous
sommes clairement depuis depuis
longtemps le longtemps ancré sur des
valeurs humanistes écologique démocrate
et nous allons continuer sur ce chemin
et avec tous ceux qui partagent ses
valeurs mais il est évident que cette
recomposition politique oblige à ne plus
réfléchir uniquement en silo boutique
par gothique mais de façon transversale
sur des sujets et il ya un sujet qui a
été très important
c'est l'un des enseignements de cette
élection c'est l'écologie écologie et
jean christophe lagarde a apporté un
volet écologique très important
vous pourrez développer et qui est
vraiment très très intéressant notamment
sur sur toutes les technologies d'avenir
l'hydrogène sur le livret européen enfin
voilà tout un tas de mesures qui étaient
vraiment très concrète mais voilà donc
il faut que l'on poursuivre sur cette
voie là et au travers des des projets
municipaux qui sur lesquels nos élus et
nos militants vont être amenés à
travailler dans les mois qui viennent
alors une juste une dernière chose en
moins d'une minute
vous parliez de la suite c'est notamment
la préparation des élections municipales
la suite à la tête de la fédération
alors 70 je proposerai parce que de mon
point de vue ce n'est pas le moment
d'organiser une nouvelle élection l'été
arrive et puis ensuite nous allons tous
être sur nos campagnes municipales
je proposerai un calendrier lors de la
réunion du début de juillet pour que ces
élections aient lieu après les élections
municipales
merci à martorell je rappelle que vous
êtes le maire de noisy le roi et vous
assurer l'intérim à la tête de la
fédération udi des yvelines vous
inscrire merci de m'avoir invité le
sport j moins un avant le début de la
coupe du monde féminine de football en
france les bleus affrontent demain la
corée du sud match d'ouverture au parc
des princes 21h et les coéquipières de
wendy renard qui se sont préparés dans
les yvelines des séances à
clairefontaine comme vous le voyez sur
ces images tournées lundi cet après-midi
les tricolores ont effectué leur dernier
entraînement à croissy sur seine le site
de la ville accueillera également
pendant la compétition les sélections
américaines sud-africaine et écossaises
à noter que demain une fan zone sera
ouverte dès 18h30 derrière le stade de
croatie accès via le skate park pour
suivre
à 21h la rencontre sur écran géant
championnat coupe de france coupe de la
ligue et trophée européen avec le
paris-saint-germain laurent fournier
aura presque tout remporté autant dire
pour le club de poissy où l'ex
international vient d'arriver sur au
poste d'entraîneur que les espoirs sont
permis pour la saison prochaine laurent
fournier qui était présenté ce matin à
la presse michael et demi d'euros et
wilfrid riches
formé à l'olympique lyonnais où il
disputera deux cent soixante matchs dans
les années 80 passé par saint-etienne
marseille et paris laurent fournier 54
ans est aujourd'hui le nouvel entraîneur
de l'as poissy conférence de presse ce
jeudi matin pour le
nouvel homme fort du football pisciacais
c'est toujours valorisant d'être sur un
terrain de
de faire partager ce que c'est ce qui
nous a permis de gagner pas mal de
titres de faire comprendre aux jeunes
que
de travailler à l'extérieur c'est
toujours mieux que de travailler à
l'intérieur et que le sport et ben c'est
le foot c'est populaire c'est ça permet
d'aller de s'extérioriser d'être bien
dans sa peau son ambition la montée
d'ici deux ans laisse poissy
actuellement national de la 4e division
française et qui vient de terminer cette
saison à la 9e place
je pense que on a effectivement d'un
côté la difficulté d'être du monde
amateur mais c'est un monde formidable
et d'un autre côté des anciens pros qui
sont fédéraux donc c'est de retrouver
l'alchimie entre ces jeunes donc ces
jeunes issus de la fois ci de les faire
monter en nationale 2 et ses anciens de
les entourer je pense que c'est très
important aujourd'hui pour réussir notre
projet le psg est le red star créteil
laurent fournier retrouve donc une place
sur le banc d'une équipe francilienne
puis de trois ans après avoir quitté son
dernier poste d'entraîneur il reprend du
service et ne devrait pas déroger à sa
réputation d' homme combatif et
possédant un certain franc-parler
j'ai pas trouvé que c'était incohérent
cette année j'ai juste trouvé qu'il y
avait les résultats étaient en dents de
scie donc peut-être problème
de mental mais on l'a vu le mental n'y a
pas que la s fois ci il ya certaines
équipes comme le paris saint germain qui
ont perdu contre manchester alors qu'ils
avaient mené 2 0 et là aussi c'est pas
un problème de qualité
c'est juste un problème de d'exigence et
quand on est exigeant je crois qu'on
arrive à faire pas mal de choses
une échéance que beaucoup patent avec
appréhension le bac 2010 9 début pour
les élèves de terminale le lundi 17 juin
avec la philosophie à des épreuves
anticipées également pour les élèves de
première et pour préparer au mieux
l'examen est la médiathèque du canal à
montigny le bretonneux organise des
coachings prépa bac pour en parler et
manuela guy bonsoir vous êtes la
coordinatrice des actions culturelles
pour les adolescents sur la médiathèque
du canal de montigny le bretonneux donc
il propose trois dates d'ateliers qui se
dérouleront les 8 12 et 15 juin il la
salle de la fabrique aussi kg et
exceptionnellement ouverte pour offrir
plus de place d'études au sein de la
médiathèque
pourquoi organiser cette opération
spéciale bac alors peut-être déjà pour
introduire très rapidement c'est vrai
que ça fait partie d'une mission
traditionnelle en fait de former les
publics en accueil peut tout au long de
l'année
bon travail avec les lycéens qu'on
construit des projets clés professeur
fait des rencontres d'auteurs et notre
nouvelle directrice avait pour projet
alors au départ on était parti sur 2020
de proposer des ateliers en fait
d'accompagnement scolaire de gestion du
stress du bien-être et des fois le
hasard fait bien les choses en fait nous
devons association qui s'appelle agora
transition faite nous a contactés pour
proposer des ateliers de coaching
scolaire et donc on s'est dit allez on y
va dès 2019 donc en quelques semaines
et bien voilà on a je pense préparé un
programme qui plutôt un beau programme
présenté dans un instant l'objectif on
imagine c'est que les lycéens arrivent
dans les meilleures conditions le jour
du bac
voilà c'est ça et le coaching scolaire
c'est plutôt contrairement au cours de
on va dire de soutien individuel que
plus classique s'intéresser vraiment à
la personnalité en fait de sa doit viser
à développer la singularité de chacun
les le potentiel on s'attache pas tant à
résultats scolaires que à la
personnalité en fait alors il ya trois
dates qui sont proposés à la médiathèque
du camel la première c'est ce samedi le
8 juin de 10h à 18h30 et là c'est une
immersion totale
quel est le programme alors six ateliers
3 pour les séries scientifiques 3 pour
les séries économiques et littéraires
non deux ateliers de mathématiques deux
heures deux ateliers un de svt un
d'histoire géo et le dernier la
philosophie donc ces deux heures un
sujet de bac temps imparti deux heures
voilà
et puis la coach quand même pour aider à
trouver là peut-être le plan organisé et
puis aussi la dynamique de groupe
donc ça c'est pour ce samedi mercredi 12
juin c'est de 10h30 à 17h30 lance là on
sera sur un entretien individualisé
c'est ça c'est ça si créneau d'une heure
je pense que chaque lycéen peut venir
avec une problématique précise quand
même parce qu'ils ont une heure on peut
pas gérer voilà tous les problèmes donc
un papa de mémorisation de concentration
sommeil à gérer voilà donc le coach est
là pour aider à identifier les trouver
des solutions des petits trucs et le
faire de manière du coût individuel
alors voilà alors que les ateliers du
samedi précédent
son groupe sis à peu près d'accord voilà
là c'est vraiment individuel individuel
alors pour terminer ce samedi 15 juin on
sera deux jours avant l'épreuve de
philosophie
gérer les examens gérer le stress aussi
on sait que ça peut faire perdre ses
moyens le stress tu as fait donc du coup
justement pour clôturer on s'est dit
voilà on va proposer un atelier de
gestion du stade donc c'est toute une
journée
c'est une journée de détente de
relaxation identifié gérer trouver les
solutions pour gérer son stress et nous
l'ouvrons quand même cet atelier parce
que finalement pour les lycéens
consacrer une journée entière à ger on
s'aperçut que nombreux étaient réticents
donc on louvre aussi à d'autres
étudiants en préparation d'examens de
concours même quelques adultes il reste
quelques places
voilà qui ont une situation de stress il
faut s'inscrire c'est ça c'est
obligatoire faut s'inscrire avec le site
donc on a le site des médiathèques
réseau des médiathèques de saint quentin
en yvelines qui s'affiche donc on peut
contacter via ce ce si long et pia
numéro de téléphone également de la
médiathèque du canal donc on peut
appeler et que l'on peut retrouver du
coup sûr sur ce site
il nous reste 30 secondes cas les
derniers conseils vous donneriez aux
lycéens de venir à aux ateliers
peut-être déjà devenir la médiathèque
aux ateliers una des places assises on a
deux autres médiathèques du réseau qui
ouvre plus leurs horaires d'ouverture à
elancourt attrape voilà ces informations
on les retrouve bien sûr sur le site du
réseau des médiathèques de saint quentin
en yvelines
c'est ça merci à emmanuel guide est
repassé sur ce plateau je rappelle que
vous êtes la coordinatrice des actions
culturelles pour le public adolescent à
la médiathèque du canal de montigny le
bretonneux st après le bac
cet été les passionnés de cheval ont
rendez vous du 2 au 4 août au haras des
bréviaires l'édition 2019 et de l'est
qu'ils rendent au a été présentée
aujourd'hui c'est la première fois que
cette manifestation phare du tourisme
équestre française se déroule dans les
yvelines les prophéties les précisions
adoré lire 11 et d'océane bazire
propriété du département des yvelines le
haras des bréviaires accueillera dans
moins de deux mois le plus gros
rassemblement européen de tourisme
équestre
près de mille cavaliers sont attendus
sur ce site de 55 hectares pour la 52e
édition de l'est qui rendent au le
maître mot c'est de partir d'où l'on
veut quand on veut avec un principe de
liberté
à travers l'itinérance à cheval à cheval
ou en attelage donc les et qui rendent
un parti des quatre coins de france et
des quatre coins d'europe voire même de
plus loin on a vu que tu aurais des
cavaliers japonais chinois russes pour
rejoindre un point de ralliement avec
trois jours de fête et convivialité à
partager avec les autres et qui
randonnent pour participer à l'est qui
rendent au il faut avoir parcouru au
moins 100 km au fil des ans cette
manifestation annuelle a permis de
structurer le tourisme équestre une
activité fortement implanté en île de
france
près de cent mille cavaliers licenciés
en ile de france pour pratiquer
l'équitation mais ont pu multiplier par
le chiffre par cinq si on compte tous
les pratiquants tous ceux qui sont
amoureux du cheval et qui à un moment ou
un autre monte à poney ou à cheval
c'est la première fois que les tirants
d'eau fait étape dans les yvelines
l'occasion pour les participants de
découvrir un peu mieux le patrimoine et
le terroir yvelinois la vision
internationale que va être les qui
rendent au va nous permettre
effectivement de mettre en avant notre
territoire les yvelines et va mettre en
avant c'est à partir ruralité j'insiste
vraiment sur cette identité rurale qui
est très forte au niveau du département
du 2 au 4 août le public pourra
également assister gratuitement au
spectacle et aux démonstrations
d'équitation qui auront lieu au haras
des bréviaires
une table ronde l'enchanteur merlin et
des chevaliers les éléments qui ont
marqué l'histoire du roi arthur l'oeuvre
créances 791 par henri à perth elle a
inspiré jérôme correas et les paladins
pour leur renouvelle la création ils se
sont associés au co chorégraphe louis et
barreaux et des artistes amateurs
mélanie poker et audrey chaillou
[Musique]
oh
le roi arthur à la recherche de sa chair
emeline compter au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
après hama dj de endel jérôme correas et
les paladins s'attaque à l'oeuvre de
henry purcell une création commandée par
le théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
à laquelle s'est associé le chorégraphe
louis barrault c'est un opéra dont ça
veut dire qu'il ya un livre est donc une
histoire
or moi j'ai beaucoup l'habitude en tant
que chorégraphe de plutôt mettre en
place des formes on va dire abstraite
c'est à dire que j'aime bien ne pas
chercher à raconter une histoire mais
plutôt à organiser dans l'espace des
formes d valable et des mouvements des
relations une création débuté il ya
plusieurs mois sur scène quatre solistes
professionnels et 300 amateurs des
adultes et des élèves des écoles du
territoire
ces quatre écoles qui sont très
différentes ça c'est aussi intéressant
puisque c'est d'aider des mondes qui
n'ont rien à voir
voilà il ya des enfants il ya des
enfants qui viennent de milieux très
aisé d'autres au contraire beaucoup
moins et c'est des gens qui se
rencontrent sur scène et qui d'un seul
coup sûr le plateau se retrouve à un
état un état d'égalité totale presque je
me suis adapté en proposant des choses
simples et en même temps c'est parfois
les choses les plus simples qui demande
le plus de concentration et d'attention
vis-à-vis du groupe en fait pendant plus
d'une heure les artistes vous emmèneront
au coeur de l'angleterre
tout en se questionnant sur les idéaux
de la chevalerie la solidarité et la
justice
et puis ils ont formé l'un des couples
les plus célèbres de la littérature
française louis aragon et elsa triolet
s'installe à saint-arnoult-en-yvelines
dans les années 50 au coeur d'un ancien
moulin aujourd'hui devenue propriété de
l'état le site permet au public de
découvrir l'intimité des deux écrivains
visite avec mélanie poker
ma petite lili chéri la maison est
acheté cette fois ci nous avons versé un
acompte et la promesse de vente est
signé nous emménageons le 20 août un
ragot charvy il est extrêmement heureux
et fier il rêve du matin au soir et me
supplie d'acheter pour une fois sans
regarder à la dépense tout ce dont j'ai
envie pour mon cabinet de travail 1951
elle à triolet annonce la nouvelle à sa
soeur la voilà propriétaire avec louis
aragon du moulin de villeneuve un moulin
du 12è 13è siècle une activité meunière
jusqu'en 1904 une dizaine de
propriétaires de puits et un coup de
coeur pour le couple d'écrivains on dit
souvent que louis aragon l'a acheté pour
elsa triolet lé russe étrangères et veut
lui offrir un petit coin de terre de
france alors c'est un peu romancée mais
c'est aussi parce que aragon avait eu la
suppression de ses droits civiques
il voulait trouver le calme et la
sérénité 1 pour écrire pour avoir
justement pour fuir un peu paris donc
ici on va rentrer dans l'univers des
lignes on est dans le bureau de louis
aragon aragon c'est un bourreau de
travail il travaille énormément c'est
vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de choses qui ont
été écrites ici
notamment on peut citer la semaine
sainte parce qu'on voit là tous ces
livres reliés cuir qui ont servi de base
à l'écriture de ce roman
les livres visible lors de la visite ne
sont qu'une petite partie de la
collection des auteurs au détour d'un
escalier un trésor
la partie immergée des ouvrages elle à
triolet et louis aragon posséder près de
trente mille livres
il veut que ce lieu soit un lieu de
recherche donc et c'est pour ça qu'on a
toutes leurs bibliothèques qui est
accessible aux artistes aux chercheurs
qui souhaitent aller plus loin dans les
hommes des deux écrivains
donc voilà donc ça c'est un lieu qui vit
et qui
et des oeuvres d'aragon et d'elsa
continue à intéresser énormément
d'universitaires le lieu se fige le 16
juin 1970 date à laquelle elle à triolet
décède louis aragon va légèrement se
détacher du moule en avant de rejoindre
son épouse enterré au coeur du parc
lorsque l à triolet va mourir en 1970
aragon va faire en sorte d'avoir une
dérogation présidentielle pour qu'ils
puissent être enterrés tous les deux ici
disparu en 1982 le journaliste c'est de
la maison à l'état français
géré par une association le moulin
continue aujourd'hui une ouverture sur
la création contemporaine voulue par
louis aragon
le site organise des expositions des
animations et le parc accueille des
sculptures la maison triolet aragon
accueille chaque année vingt mille
visiteurs dans son parc de près de 6
hectares
[Musique]
magnifique site à découvrir à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines et pour
d'autres idées de sorties c'est dans un
instant l'émission 7,8 loisirs présenté
par marylène iapichino c'est la fin de
ce set 8 journal et j'aurai le plaisir
de vous retrouver dès mardi pour une
nouvelle édition belle soirée à tous
[Musique]